The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we are
going to discuss color vision
and adaptation.
About 2/3 of it's going
to be color vision and one
third on adaptation.
Now, I'm going to have several
demonstrations on the screen
here for you.
And I would like to forewarn
on you that for some reason,
they still haven't fixed the
light bulb in this projector.
And this, you see this is a
bluish color to it, speaking
of color vision?
And actually, it's
supposed to be gray.
But there's some loss of
balance there in this bulb.
And they've promised to
replace it some 10 days ago
and it still hasn't happened.
So once we come to
the demonstrations,
they're not going to be perfect.
But they will also be
available on the internet,
as well on Stellar.
So you can look at them
there and maybe you'll
get a better picture of
them there than here.
But we'll do the best we can.
So anyway, let me
first give you a list
of things we are
going to discuss
and the questions
we're going to pose.
First of all, you're going to
ask, what are the basic facts
and laws of color vision?
Now, one of the nice
things about color vision
is that their number of laws--
it's a very basic phenomenon.
And its in many ways
very close to physics.
The second one is, what are the
major theories of color vision
that we are going to discuss?
And then we are
going to examine how
color is processed in
the retina geniculate.
Then we're going to
move on and examine
what happens in the cortex.
And then we are
going to discuss what
is the nature of
colorblindness, which
I think will be of
interest to most of you
because colorblindness is not
that uncommon, unfortunately,
among humans.
And then we're going to
look at how adaptation
is achieved in
the visual system.
That's when we switch
from color to adaptation.
And then we are going to ask the
question, what are afterimages?
How are they produced?
And what are its effects?
So let's begin, then,
with color vision.
And the first thing I would
like to say about this
is that as so often happens in
the course of history, often
there had been great
misconceptions about color.
And one of the
great misconceptions
was that people thought that
white light is the pure light.
And that was
exemplified in the fact
that before the 20th century,
for example, most nuns
were required to
wear a white outfit.
They were asked to
wear the white outfit
because it meant
that they were pure.
So what happened
then in the 1600s,
one of the greatest geniuses
of our time came along.
That was Newton.
And at that time-- this is just
an interesting coincidence--
it happened that the art of
making chandeliers has emerged.
And the chandeliers
in those cases
consisted of little pieces
of glass cut in various ways.
And people noticed, and
so especially did Newton,
that when you looked
at these chandeliers,
you saw all sorts
of colors there.
And so Newton said, my god.
How can that be?
What's going on?
And so he began
to analyze color,
which also came
about then for him
because that's when they also,
in addition to the chandeliers,
they came up with prisms.
And so what Sir Isaac
Newton did was--
let me skip this for a minute
and I'll come back to it.
What he did was that he put
a little opening in a screen
and let the light come
through from the sun.
White light.
And then he put that beam
of light through a prism.
And he discovered
that he got an image
much like what you see when
you have these chandeliers.
Namely, that you get all
sorts of colors projecting out
of the prism.
And then he performed yet
another little experiment.
He added another
prism, same kind
of prism, where the light
was separated from the red.
And then there was no
further separation.
That was a remarkable
discovery on his part.
And he became interested not
only in the physics of it,
but he also became
very interested in how
we organize our
color perceptions.
And he was the first
person to come up
with what I will talk a lot
about, the so-called color
circle.
So this is what Sir Isaac
Newton then came up with.
And he established that we have
a huge range of frequencies.
And a very narrow
section of it right here
is the one that falls
into the visible range.
And if you break that up
like this and enlarge it,
much like the
colors of a rainbow,
you see all of these colors.
And so the conclusion
to which he came
is something that
was quite remarkable.
He was at that age
just 29 years old.
And that was done-- to go
back here-- at the age of 29
in 1672.
And so he concluded at
that time that white light
is a mixture of all the colors.
It's white because
it's an equal mixture
of the different
wavelengths here.
So rather than being
pure, white light
is a conglomeration of
all the little wavelengths
in the visible range
that the eye can process.
So that was so stunning
for him at the time
that he delayed publication
of it for more than 30 years.
And then when he
published this, this
was extensively debated
even 30 years later.
And one of the people
who debated it a lot
was a famous German
poet called Goethe.
You probably all of
you know who he is.
And he said, Newton
is a charlatan.
He just made this up.
It can't possibly be so.
White light is pure.
And so what he did, he took
a prism just like Newton did.
But instead of reflecting the
light, he looked into the prism
towards the light and he
didn't see any colors.
And he said, Newton
is all full of junk.
And so he asked his associates
at the time, Schopenhauer,
who is also a very
famous philosopher,
and said, why don't you
do some experiments?
Let us prove that
Newton is all wrong.
And so Schopenhauer did the
experiment right and said,
oh my god, Newton is right.
What am I going to do?
How can I tell Goethe,
my boss, that he's wrong
and Newton is right?
So that became quite a thorn
in his hide at the time.
But of course
eventually, we all came
to recognize indeed that
this is the situation,
and that white light is
a mixture of all colors.
So let me now go
back a minute to some
of the basic facts, which I
will elaborate on as we proceed.
First of all, when
we talk about color,
there are all kinds
of systematic things
that we are going to discuss.
And you're going
to become educated
about the processing
of color as a result
because we know a lot of very
important basic facts about it.
It's solid science.
So when we talk about
color, we typically
make a distinction between hue,
brightness, and saturation.
Hue means what is the color.
Is it red, green, and blue?
Brightness is how intense
the impression is.
And saturation is that every
color can be kind of washed out
or it can be very sharp.
Can you see a bright red?
Or you can see a
really washed-out red
that's barely different
from the background?
This is very important.
We have to make a
clear distinction
between the psychological
and physiological attributes,
or the physical, actually,
attributes of color.
So what do we mean by that?
When we talk about color,
that's an impression we have.
That's our own personal
psychological experience.
But the scientific way to look
at it is to call it wavelength.
The same thing is true for
luminance and brightness.
Now before I go onto this,
let me back up for a minute.
Here, let me say one
more thing about this
because it's an interesting
way to remember it
and also it's relevant
to what you are going
to hear in the second
half of this course, which
is going to be on audition.
So here's a classic question
people have often been asked,
especially when you were still
in grammar school or maybe even
in high school.
It was, when a tree
falls in the forest,
and there's nobody around,
does it make a sound?
And so people debate this, and
debate this, and debate this.
Well, from my point
of view, there's
no question there at all.
When a tree falls in
the forest and there
are all these cracks
and everything,
there is no sound because sound
is a psychological attribute
that we hear and interpret.
There is, of course,
the production
of wavelengths as a
result of the fall.
So that's up in the air there.
But you need a human being to
turn that various frequencies
into what we call sound.
So now the next thing I would
like to briefly approach--
I'm going to talk about it in
much more detail in a minute--
is that it's been
established by now,
but initially there
was quite a debate--
I'll come back to it-- that we
have three major kinds of cone
receptors in humans
and in many primates.
And actually, in some
animals and some birds,
there are actually four of them.
And these three are the short,
middle, and long wavelength
cones.
Of course, we can call those--
for short, we mean blue,
for medium, we mean green,
and for long, we mean red.
And then we have the rods.
And these numbers here--
this one is misspelled.
bb?
I don't know what bb is.
At any rate, these are
nanometers at which they peak.
And we'll come back
to that in a minute.
But before I go on with that,
let's imagine for a minute--
and we can skip this.
Suppose that you are the
emperor of the universe
since the beginnings of time
1,500 million years ago.
And you decided that you're
going to create animals.
And once you've
created animals, you
have decided that they're
going to have to see things.
And so they have to have
an eye with which to see.
And then you have to decide,
well, if that's the case,
color is very important.
You looked around in
the world and said,
oh, all these beautiful colors.
How are we going to have
these animals and these humans
see all the colors?
And then you said, well,
there are hundreds of colors.
So what are we going to do?
Are we going to
create the receptor
for every one of these colors
and put them in the eye?
And you said, oh dear, that's
a problem because then we
would need a gigantic eye.
And so the question
became, of course,
how else would you
come around this?
And so here the idea, that
here you have sensitivity,
and then here you
have wavelength.
And so the idea was that
you could create hundreds
of very sharply tuned
photoreceptors like that
so you could get all the colors.
Well, that did not seem to be a
very good way of doing things.
And so getting more back
to the present time--
still a long ways off from
the present, actually-- people
began to hypothesize about,
they say, well, what can
we do to minimize the
number of receptors
with different
sensitivities color
and still be able to see well?
And so one theory that came
up before they knew anything
about the eye and the
three cone photoreceptors,
Young and Helmholtz
came up with the idea
that if you had just
three types of cones
that are broadly
tuned, they could
take care of most of the
ability to see various colors.
And so that became
a very interesting,
very, very powerful theory.
And actually, speaking
of theories and models,
it still is in my mind
probably the greatest model
or theory that has
ever been developed
about how the brain works
because it subsequently
did turn out that
indeed, there were three
of these receptors that are
broadly tuned that can provide
all that information for you.
And that actually, as you
will see, became a huge issue.
Sorry.
Let me go back for
a minute to this.
And let me just reiterate.
These are the nanometers for
the three types of cones.
And at the end here, we have
the nanometers for the rods.
Then as a result of
analyzing all this stuff,
people have come up with
all sorts of rules and laws.
And that's what is one of the
nice things about color vision.
And one of the rules is called--
actually, laws in this case--
is called Grassmann's laws.
And he said every color
has a complimentary which,
when mixed properly,
yields gray.
And I will explain this to
you in just a few minutes.
And the other is that
non-complementary colors
yield intermediates.
Just keep that in your head for
me until I fully explain it.
And the other law, which I'm not
going to talk too much about,
is that the luminance of a
mixture of differently colored
lights is equal to the
sum of the luminance
of its components.
So these are very, very
basic rules-- laws.
So here we go
again, and move on.
Here is what is called the
CIE chromaticity diagram.
And it was initially
devised in 1931.
And let me explain to
you how this came about.
This became an
international undertaking.
And it came about
because it was highly
desirable to be
able to communicate
throughout the world
your particular color
desire or experience.
So for example, if you had a
particular hat you had bought,
say a blue hat of some
sort, and then said
now I would like to get
a dress that fits it.
How can I do that?
Well, what you can
do now as a result
of this chromaticity diagram,
there's a scale here.
You can see the vertical values
and the horizontal values
going from 0 to close to 100.
And then, if you can
specify a particular color,
say you want this
color here, you simply
can state what that color
is by giving it the number.
And then you can send that
number to China or to,
I don't know, to South
Africa or something,
to a particular
company, and say I
want to have a dress like
that with that color.
And then because this
is international,
they were able to
produce that color
as you specified
on this diagram.
So that was a very
powerful undertaking.
And this arrangement is such
that actually, the colors
go from the center outward,
become more saturated.
Think, for example, we're
going to here to here.
And the center of this,
which is about 333 333
on the chromaticity
diagram, is white,
which is not that obvious
here, partly because
of the colors of the background.
So that is the famous
1931 chromaticity diagram.
And what one can do with
this is to superimpose
on this some rules
about the human or, say,
the primate color
vision abilities.
And the person who came up
with this, as I've mentioned,
was Newton.
He came up with the so-called
famous color circle.
Now, the color circle
is described here.
And I'll show it to you
in just a minute head-on.
This is green, this is red,
this is yellow, this is blue.
And of course, the
question is, why do we
have them set up
in this fashion?
And we'll explain
that in just a minute.
So here is the color circle, the
two-dimensional color circle,
where things are pretty
much equiluminant across it.
Now, if you go from
the center out,
you increase saturation,
as I had already said.
And as you go around,
you change hue.
So those are the
basic attributes.
Now to anticipate
the issues here,
let me tell you this-- this
is yellow, this is blue,
this is green, and this is red.
These are called
the cardinal axes.
As long as a line goes
through the center,
that's a cardinal axis.
These are the ones
which are best known,
the red/green and blue/yellow.
And the fascinating
fact about this
is that this explains a number
of very interesting facts
about our ability to see colors.
So let me tell you this--
if you mix yellow and blue,
as we have talked about
the law, if you mix them
in equal luminances, you get
what's in the center here.
You get white.
Furthermore, and
because of this,
there is no such
experience in our existence
that's called yellowish blue.
And there's no such
existence in our minds,
as far as color's concerned,
that's reddish green.
On the other hand, if you
don't go across the center,
but you say you had yellow
here and you have green here,
there is yellowish green.
There is yellowish red.
There is bluish red.
And there's bluish green.
So we can process those and
see those in-between colors,
but we cannot do that
along the cardinal axes.
So this incredible
color circle essentially
explains the very essence
of how we can see color.
Now, there's one more
factor here, is that we also
have to take into
account luminance values.
And so people turn this color
circle for some purposes
into a three-dimensional
entity that's shown here.
Here's a color circle.
And the third dimension
going up and down here,
as you go from white to black,
if you will, in the center.
So here, things are brighter
and here, things are darker.
So that is sort of
a complete, then,
arrangement for your
color impressions.
But what we are
going to do, we are
going to concentrate on
the color circle itself
as we move along.
So now let's next turn
to the outgrowth of this,
starting with Newton's color
circle, which has been somewhat
modified in the manner
that I had just shown you.
And as a result of all this,
a number of competing theories
have emerged.
And I'm going to talk
about two of them.
The first one is the famous
Young-Helmholtz theory.
Young initially, and he
collaborated with him
many years later,
with Helmholtz,
came up with the idea that
you could experience colors
by just having three types of
cones that are broadly tuned.
And so he said there
are three types
of broadly tuned
color receptors.
The color experience
is the product
of the relative
degree of activation.
Now, that's a fantastic theory.
But there's a big
problem with it.
The big problem
with that theory is
that he doesn't explain
Grassmann's laws.
Remember what
Grassmann's law is?
That if you mix things along the
cardinal axes, you get white.
And you only get
other colors when
you mix them not along the axes.
So that became a problem.
And because of that, another
famous person, Herring,
came up with an
alternate theory.
He came up with a theory which
said that color opponency is
based on the observation
that red and green, as well
as blue and yellow, are mutually
exclusive, just as I had said.
The nervous system
probably treats
red/green and blue/yellow
as antagonistic pairs,
with a third pair
being black and white.
That's where the third
dimension comes in.
So therefore he argued
that we need something
like color opponency to be
able to see colors right.
Now, the interesting
thing about this
is that he became
very famous coming up
with this incredible theory.
But then if you go
back in history,
you find that Leonardo da
Vinci had this same idea
many, many, many
years before that.
And this is from
his autobiography,
with a very poor translation.
It says, "Of different
colors equally perfect,
that will appear
most excellent, which
is seen near its
direct contrary,
blue near yellow,
green near red,
because each color is seen,
when opposed to its contrary,
than any other similar to it."
It's not written in English
really, but you get the idea.
So we have a major two theories.
And then numerous
experiments subsequently
emerge, especially
when it became
possible to record the
neural activity of cells
to determine to what degree
these theories are correct.
And of course, the first
correct aspect of both theories
was that indeed, we have
three types of cones
that are selected to
red, green, and blue,
and that they are broadly tuned.
So to now understand
better how it really
happens in the nervous
system, let's take a look
at the basic physiology
of color processing.
I showed you this
slide once before.
I pointed out to
you that contrary
to red and green cones, blue
cones are much less numerous.
Only one out of eight are blue.
And furthermore,
if you look at this
in the retinal surfaces
in the fovea area,
there appear to be very few
blue ones in the fovea itself.
So the blue cones
are less numerous.
And consequently,
it became a puzzle
of how do they contribute
to color vision.
Now, to exemplify this further,
let me show you a slide here.
Here what we vary is
a spatial frequency.
And what you can see
is-- I think most of you
probably don't
see anything here.
But most of you
probably still see this.
This is the same spatial
frequency as this.
But this activates
the blue cones mostly.
And this activates
your red cones.
And you can see that your
acuity is much, much lower
when you only have your
blue cones available.
And that's because only
one out of eight blue cones
exist in the retina.
So there's this very,
very clear distinction.
So now let's talk about
the photoreceptors.
Here we have an
absorption spectrum,
or I should say a series
of absorption spectra,
for the four kinds
of photoreceptors.
And the fourth one is your rods.
So what you see here--
and each of them
are fairly broadly tuned.
Here we have nanometers.
And I'm sure all of
you know this already,
that 1 nanometer is a
billionth of a meter.
So we're talking about
incredibly, incredibly
high frequencies.
So that the important
thing to remember here
is that each of these cones
is fairly broadly tuned.
And so consequently, any light
that comes into the eye tends
to activate all of the cones
unless they're at the very
extremes. .
And so indeed, as Young
and Helmholtz had proposed,
somehow we have to derive
our color experience
from the relative
amount of activity
from these different cone types.
But then as I've
mentioned to you,
Herring felt that that was not
sufficient to explain our color
abilities.
And so what he did then is
to move on and had people,
especially much more recently,
examine more closely what
the center-surround organization
is of the different midget
cells in the retina.
And if you remember,
initially I told you
that the prime theory was
that the center comes up,
is comprised in the central
retina of just a single cone
and the surround of its
color opponent cone.
But then, when people began to
study this very carefully using
a combination of
recordings and anatomy,
they found that actually
the surround is not
specific to one
type of cone input.
It's mixed.
And so then people
began to model that.
And they found that
this arrangement
is almost as good
as this arrangement.
And this is the truth, actually.
That's how it is.
And so then, just to remind
you, the parasol cells
have a mixture of these
inputs, both in the center
and the surround.
And as we had discussed, the
parasol system cannot tell you
about colors.
This I mentioned to you before.
The midget system gives
a more sustained response
than the parasol system.
So now I also showed
you this diagram.
And we established that the
green and the red cones each
give rise to an
on and off system
at the level of
the bipolar cells,
and then give rise to the
on and off ganglion cells.
The red and green on
and off ganglion cells.
Now, the blue system
is more complicated
because if you would have had
four different kinds of cones,
meaning a blue one
and a yellow one,
then probably would have
had a similar arrangement.
But nature somehow had failed to
create a yellow cone because it
felt it was not necessary--
because if you have
an equal mix of red and
green, you get yellow,
because remember,
they're not on opposites.
Sorry.
They're opposite.
But if you mix them, you can
create an impression of yellow
because they're not along
the exact axes for the colors
themselves.
So the argument was
therefore that you
must have blue on and
blue/yellow on ganglion cells.
But whether this
is really the case
is still to some degree debated.
People have done a
lot of recordings.
And much of this
was done not only
in the retina, but also your
lateral geniculate nucleus.
And so the question
was, let's just
find out what is the
color tuning of cells
in the lateral geniculate
nucleus to understand this.
And to do this, when we went
back to the color circle
and presented stimuli
along the color circle
through the receptive
fields of these cells
to see how they responded.
And here's an example of
a so-called blue ON cell.
It shows here you [INAUDIBLE]
the cell is tuned.
Sharply tuned,
mostly to 90 degrees.
The yellow cell is the opposite.
And green OFF cell here
and a green ON cell here.
So what happens then is when you
take a lot of sample of these,
huge sample of
them, what you find
is that in the lateral
geniculate nucleus,
you don't get any cells
that are at the diagonals.
All the cells fall into
these major four categories
along your cardinal axes.
And then if you take
a big huge sample,
you come up with the
following summary--
that you have red ON
cells, red OFF cells.
You have green ON cells and
you have green OFF cells.
And at least some people
claim that you only
have blue ON and Yellow ONs.
You don't have blue
OFFs and yellow OFFs.
That is still under debate.
But certainly, if you
do extensive recordings,
if you find any OFF
blue and yellow OFFs,
they're extremely rare
if they exist at all.
So now to try to gain
yet further understanding
of the role various areas
play in color vision,
is that one can make lesions.
And I've already
told you what happens
when you make either
parvocellular or magnocellular
lesion.
That blocks the parasol
or the midget systems.
And that the midget system is
essential for color vision.
And then I showed you this.
Here is a geniculate.
If you take out this area,
you block the midget system.
And if you take out this area,
you block the parasol system.
So if you do that--
here is an overall view
of the monkey brain.
Here's area V1 Here's the V2.
And here's area V4, which
I've mentioned to you
before had been believed to
play a central role in color.
So then it becomes
important to see just
what happens when you make
lesions in these areas.
In this case, you
can make a lesion V4.
And then we can examine
color discrimination.
And I told you in
a monkey, what you
do is you use an oddity task.
After fixation, you can
present the odd stimulus either
in the intact parts
of the visual field
or those that had been lesions.
This is a high contrast.
And if you do that
experiment-- I
showed you part of
this data before.
I showed you that after
lesion of the parvocellular
geniculate, which blocks
the midget system,
you totally lose the
ability to discriminate
even these high colors,
red, green, and blue.
But no deficit
arises when you make
a lesion in the magnocellular
portion of the geniculate.
And then the big
question became what
happens in V4, since
that had for decades been
declared to be a color area.
And what was surprising about
that is that after V4 lesion,
there was only a
small deficit in color
for this high-contrast stimuli.
So therefore people have to
go on and do a more careful
detailed study to
see what happens
if you use less
saturated colors.
Remember that the
degree of saturation
is one of the important
factors for analyzing color.
And here we have an example
of a very low saturation.
And here we have a
somewhat high saturation.
And you can vary
that systematically
and see what happens
after V4 lesion
and after other
kinds of lesions.
And here's an example of
what happens in a V4 lesion.
And this is what
happens in an MT lesion.
It shows no deficit at
all with an MT lesion,
indicating that MT does
not play a crucial role
in analyzing color.
We do get this
significant deficit here,
but it's a small one.
So even at low
saturations, the monkey
still can do colors
reasonably well.
So it's not like V4
is the color area.
There apparently
are several areas
in the brain that
can process color.
And V4 does that in
addition to performing
several other analyses
that we will discuss
in a couple of
sessions from now.
So now we're going to turn
to another very interesting
phenomenon, which is what
is called isoluminance.
What is isoluminance?
Isoluminance is the
presentation of different colors
that have the same
illumination level.
So I'm going to give you
a few examples of this.
If you look at this--
how many of you
can read those words there?
Pretty tough, isn't it?
This can be set up in such
a way that it's even worse.
But because of the light bulb in
there, it's not really perfect.
But just to give
you a sense of it
obviously goes to a
lot easier to read.
So that's because this
is close to isoluminance,
at which our ability to see
objects is much impeded.
Not eliminated, but impeded.
So what can you do to do
this kind of experiment
systematically?
What you can do here is you
can use various capabilities.
Stereopsis, motion parallax--
just motion-- and texture.
And if you do that, and you vary
the red/green luminance ratio,
you can see that there's a
dramatic drop off at around
very close to a luminous
ratio of one and one.
So indeed, our ability
to process information
in the absence of
luminance information
is greatly compromised.
So then the question
came up-- I mean,
we're talking about here such
things as motion perception,
texture perception,
and stereopsis.
And as we had
discussed before, we
have already established that
texture and stereopsis are
processed to a large extent
by the midget system.
And that motion
to a large extent
is processed by
the parasol system.
But all three of these
types of capabilities
are compromised isoluminance
So a series of experiments
had been carried out
in which people argued that
when you present stimuli
at isoluminance, you render
the parasol system unresponsive
because it gets equal input
in the center-surround,
some red and green
cones and blue cones.
So therefore, they
concluded, that if there's
a deficit in
performance like this,
that must reflect the fact
that the parasol system plays
an important role
in the analysis.
But as I told you
before, stereopsis
is processed predominantly
by the midget system
and so is texture.
So that raised quite a problem.
And so people began to run
experiments in which they
recorded from the parasol system
to see what happens actually
to unit responses when
you are at isoluminance.
And that resulted
in quite a surprise.
So here is an example
of a magnocellular cell,
meaning a cell that gets
input from the parasol system
of the retina.
And you alternate between red
and green here repeatedly,
collect the data, and you
vary the red/green ratio.
And you can see here that
throughout the whole thing,
the cell continues to respond.
So that became quite a puzzle.
We were not able to
silence the magnocellular
system at isoluminance.
So the question is, how come?
Well, the answer is,
as you had seen before,
that the parasol system
is extremely sensitive.
It gets input even in the
center of the receptive
field of each cell
for many of-- I
should maybe say
several-- different cones.
And because of that,
there's much more
information and excitation
coming into those cells
than into those that
are in the midget system
that most of which
only get input
from a single cone
for the center.
So that being the case
then, we can move on
and ask a question
of what about if you
do the same kind of
experiment in area MT.
Now, who remembers?
Area MT gets most of its
input from which system?
Good.
Mostly from the parasol system
going through the magnocellular
layers.
So now you can
record in the area MT
and do the same kind of
experiment I just described
to you the retina in the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
And so what you can do
here is you have a monkey.
The monkey fixates.
And you move a bar of light
across the receptor field
back and forth which is
isoluminant-- red/green
in this case.
And then you see how
well the cell responds.
And then for comparison
what you can do
is you can use a luminance
grading, bright and dark
in the background,
to which we know
that the parasol cells and
the cells in the area MT
respond vigorously.
So now we are going to
compare what the difference is
between these two conditions,
meaning luminance grading as
opposed to an isoluminant
color grading.
So if you do that experiment,
you're in for surprise.
Here's an example of one
cell in which there's
a much more vigorous
response to luminance.
Here are the various
luminance contrasts.
And here is a chrominance one.
And the cell doesn't
respond as well here,
but it still responds
reasonably well.
Then you take another cell
and you get the opposite.
And this particular
cell, still in area MT,
responds a bit more
vigorously to chrominance
than to luminance.
And so if you add
this all up and record
for many, many cells, you
find that the cells in area
MT, just like in the
lateral geniculate nucleus
and in the retina, respond
quite well at isoluminance--
the parasol cells and the
same cells, of course,
in the lateral geniculate
nucleus, and in area MT.
So this area MT is one that
responds surprisingly well
to anything that's out there
that results in a change,
whether the change is produced
by virtue of chrominance
or by virtue of luminance.
And that, in fact, is one of
the very important attributes
of the parasol system.
Namely, and that's so
numerous in the periphery,
is to be able to detect just
about anything that happens--
motion, flicker, just the onset
of a single stimulus, whatever.
But that system
is very sensitive
and can tell something
has happened there.
That's what that system
is very good for.
It's not that good,
obviously, for seeing
very, very fine detail.
But it's very sensitive.
And it's very, very
good for detecting
motion and appearances.
So now we're going to move
on and talk about a topic
that I'm sure many of
you have an interest in.
And that has to do with
deficiencies in color,
often referred to
as color blindness.
And the first fact
is that if you
look at the incidence of
color deficits in humans,
8 out of 100 males among
Caucasians, 5 in a 100
in Asians, 3 in a
100 in Africans.
In females, it's
much, much less.
It's 10 times less frequent.
But still overall,
that's quite a number
of people who have some
sort of deficiency in color.
So now that we know that, we
can ask the next question-- what
kinds of color
deficits can we denote?
And the type, these are
given fancy names, which
are called protanopes,
deuteranopes, and tritanopes.
And that simply
refers to the fact
that protanopes lack
long-wavelength cones, which
are of course the red cones.
The deuteranopes lack
medium-wavelength cones,
if you talk green ones.
And the tritanopes lack
the short-wavelength cones,
which are the blue ones.
So that is the basic
types of deficits.
Now, some people have
a combination of these.
Some people have no color vision
at all, but that's very rare.
Quite common are
these three types.
You somehow don't have one
particular kind of cone
or you have very few of
them, or you have them,
but they don't function right.
So now, how do we establish
our ability to see colors
and whether we have
normal color vision?
Now, that's very interesting.
A number of tests
have been developed.
And the most famous of
those, the oldest one--
let me go back, sorry-- are
the so-called Ishihara plates.
And the next one's the
Farnsworth-Munsell Hue Test.
And the third one I was
going to tell you about
is the dynamic computer test.
So let's look at
the Ishihara plates
If you look at that,
how many of you
can see what is written there?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Eight.
PROFESSOR: Eight.
Very good.
Anybody who doesn't see it?
OK, you don't see that.
We'll get back to
you in a minute.
So now another test
is a dynamic one.
The reason for
using a dynamic test
is that the
so-called isoluminant
point of individuals
is not the same.
Expect a lot of variations
from person to person.
And so this test
is the dynamic one.
They presented for
the background,
as you can see here, different
luminance levels in gray.
And when the computer
starts running,
these keep exchanging each
other in randomized fashions.
It's the dynamic view.
And then you have a
central area here.
Everybody can read this, right?
What's the word?
AUDIENCE: Lite.
PROFESSOR: Lite.
Very good.
So now instead of presenting
these letters here
in a high brightness overall,
we can present them in color.
So I'm now going to
show you an easy test.
Anybody can read this?
Anybody who cannot read it?
Can you read it?
AUDIENCE: Ish.
PROFESSOR: Ish.
So what's the word?
AUDIENCE: MIT.
PROFESSOR: MIT.
What's that?
So now I'm going to
make it more difficult.
You guys ready?
What is this one?
AUDIENCE: Fit.
PROFESSOR: Are you having a--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
a little harder.
PROFESSOR: You're
having a fit, huh?
Can you read that one?
AUDIENCE: No, I can't.
PROFESSOR: No.
So now it seems like we
do have one person here
who has perhaps a
mild color deficiency.
And so now the question
comes up, even if all of you
want to do this, what can
you do to test yourself?
Well, so let me
tell you about that.
There is a so-called
Farnsworth-Munsell color test.
So what you want to do here is--
can you read this down here?
Get on Google and just type in
Farnsworth-Munsell color test
online.
If you type that in, all
kinds of things come up.
Click on the topmost one.
And then what you see
here is a set of colors.
Actually, there are four sets.
And each of these has 20.
And I just drew
a few of them in.
And your task is
then-- each of these
can be moved-- to
arrange them in an order,
going from this color
to that color in order.
So you do that for
all four of them.
And after did that, you
can click on the bottom.
And it will tell you what your
score is for each of these.
And so if your color
vision is very good,
it gives you sort of
a set of histograms.
And if the histogram is very,
very low, then you're good.
And if it's high,
then you're not.
What you can actually do is
when this first comes on,
these are in random order.
Your task is to
put them in order.
But at the bottom
here, it says score.
So if you click on
score, it will give you
the histograms uncorrected.
And they're all
going to be high.
Then you do this work.
And then you click
on it again and see
how good your color
vision is based on that.
It's a bit time-consuming.
But if you are interested in
getting a sense of just how
good your color vision is,
this is a rather good test,
which is readily
available on the internet.
Does anybody have any
questions about this portion?
Good.
So now as a result
of this, we're
going to move on and spend the
remainder of our time talking
about adaptation because that is
pretty closely relevant, as we
shall see, to color
vision as well.
So I'm going to talk
about adaptation.
First of all, again we come up
with a number of basic facts.
Now let me at this
point interject
and just tell you
that all the material
I'm talking about today
will be posted on Stellar.
What's on Stellar now is
not an updated version.
But what I'm talking about
today will be on Stellar
I think by tomorrow.
So basic facts.
We talk about overall
levels of illumination.
That's what's so remarkable
about the visual system.
It's actually unbelievable.
10 log units overall.
But the reflected light varies
over much smaller range.
In other words, you don't want
to look at directly at light.
The reflected light
varies only about 20 fold.
So now the question is,
how do we handle this?
Well, it turns out
that the pupil, which
does play a role
in this, can only
adjust over a range of 16 to 1.
So that's a long cry
from 10 log units.
And so much of the
adaptation I would
say, even more so the
adaptation that takes place,
occurs in your photoreceptors.
So here I'm saying this
again-- most light adaptation
takes place in the
photoreceptors.
Now, how does it take place?
Well, the way it takes place is
that-- I mentioned this to you
before-- the photoreceptor
molecules, like rhodopsin
in the rods, comes
in two basic forms.
You don't need to know
the chemistry of it,
but you make two or simply
that it comes in two forms.
We can call it bleached
and unbleached.
Some people call
it open and closed.
But let's call it
bleached and unbleached.
This is very dynamic process.
At any level of illumination a
certain percentage of molecules
is bleached in each receptor
and a certain number
is not bleached.
And the brighter the
illumination, the more
are bleached.
It's dynamic, which I mean is
that the molecules constantly
keep changing.
So it's the overall
percentage of the ratios
between the beached
and the unbleached.
So that means that any increase
in the rate of which quanta
is delivered to the eye results
in a proportional decrease
in the number of pigment
molecules available to absorb
those quanta because
they are bleached.
Now, this arrangement happens
to be extremely clever.
And this is
reflected in the fact
that the retinal ganglion cells
are sensitive to local contrast
differences.
Remember, I told you there's a
center-surround organization.
This is one of the prime
reasons we have that.
The overwhelming
majority, like 95%
of the cells in the retina,
the retinal ganglion cells,
respond to contrast
differences, not
to absolute levels
of illumination.
And that's how we often
talk about contrast.
And if you remember what
the contrast formula is,
it's the contrast level
of the stimulus itself
and the contrast level
of the background.
You subtract one from the other,
divided by the sum of the two,
multiplied by 100.
I showed that to you before.
So now here we are.
If you talk about light
and dark adaptation,
this is the basic outline
of the retinal connections
that we have talked about.
We have presented this
several times before.
And then if you
are light adapted,
you essentially have
non-functional rods,
so I took them off here.
But then when you darken
that, the opposite happens.
And you have the rods active.
But they all fit into
the same ganglion cells.
And that's why at night, the
receptor fields are bigger.
And you don't see color
at night because this
is what the picture is.
Now what you can do is
let's ask the question,
how do the neurons, like
the cells in the retina,
the retinal ganglion
cells how do they
fire at different
levels of illumination?
And that's quite an
interesting story
and a very straightforward one.
Here we have a cell
that had been adapted
to these different levels
of background illumination.
At minus 5, your
rods are functional.
And what is
important to see here
is that as you change quite
dramatically the background
level, the eye adapts.
And I should say that it's the
photoreceptors predominately
that do so.
And what they look at
are local differences.
And so each of these
then sees a fresh,
the contrast that is
created, rather than looking
at absolute illumination levels.
And that's what you
want, of course.
You want to be able to
drive well at night.
drive well in the daytime.
And by having this system,
you can look at predominantly
at contrast
differences rather than
absolute levels of contrast.
So that's the arrangement here.
And now what we
are going to do is
to move on and talk about
the so-called after-effects
of adaptation.
So let me tell you how
this initially was done.
People ask the question, what
happens if I fix something
on your retina for
a period of time?
If that previous set of
data that I've shown you
is correct, if I present
something to the retina
and leave it there, pretty
soon you won't see anything.
A famous series
of experiments was
done, by now many,
many years ago,
in which they-- very
clever experiment--
had subjects lie down.
And they put a contact
lens in the eye.
And in the contact lens, they
put a miniature projector on,
which meant that when you
turn that projector light on,
it went to a fixed position
on the retinal surface.
Why was this necessary?
Well, the reason it
happened is because it
was discovered that
your eye actually
is not really stable on purpose.
Your eye ha a
so-called eye tremor.
And of course, you move
your eyes all the time.
So this procedure of
having a contact lens
with a projector
attached to it kind of
got rid of the eye tremor.
So when they did
that, they found that,
depending on the contrast, in
a matter of a minute or less,
maybe even 30 seconds,
you would stop
seeing what was
presented to the eye
because you then
change the adaptation
level in your photoreceptors.
So then subsequently,
people had a clever idea.
Said, we don't need to go
through this incredible trouble
of having to have people with
contact lenses and a projector,
and having them lie
down because that's
the only way it would work.
We can do this much more simply.
And so to do that, I'm going
to have a demonstration here.
What I would like
each of you to do
is to-- you see it's a light
spot here and dark spot there.
So I want you to fixate
here and count to about 30.
And be very relaxed about it.
This is a Gaussian.
Therefore there's no sharp
edge and the eye tremor
doesn't matter.
Then after you counted
to 30, shift your gaze
to the bottom one.
The first thing
that happens if you
keep looking at it,
the two on the top
here disappear if you
fixate very tightly.
And once they disappear,
then you can look down.
Everybody see it disappear?
Good.
And what happened when
you looked at the bottom?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You got
a reversal, right?
You got a dark spot here
and a light spot here.
And you say oh my god,
what's going on here?
So now let's do
another experiment.
I want you to do this again.
But what I want you to do is
to cover one eye up and then
do it again.
Count to 30.
And after you did so, make
[INAUDIBLE] down the bottom,
but switch your eye.
And if you switch the eye,
cover the one that you looked at
and uncover the one
that you didn't look at.
And if you do that, you
won't get any effect.
So what does that prove?
That prove that this is
happening in the retina.
Everybody agree?
Very clear cut.
So what's going on here?
So let's diagram this.
Here we have the situation.
You turned on these two stimuli.
And then when we turn it down,
initially their sensitivity
of your photoreceptors
is pretty much the same
because it was a
homogeneous background.
Then after you looked at this
for awhile-- no, one more
thing.
In this case, the ON cells
fired, and in this case,
the OFF cells fired, saying,
oh, dark spot, oh, light spot.
Now, if you keep looking at
this for awhile, what happens
is it begins to disappear.
When it does, what happens
is you don't see anything
and what happens also is that
the sensitivity here decreases
for white light and [INAUDIBLE]
increases here for white light.
So therefore, what happens
is once you adapted to this,
there is no response
in the ganglion cells.
Then for the third step.
When you've made
yourself look down,
there were homogeneous
background.
But this region is less and
this region's more sensitive.
And so therefore the
photons come into your eye
from those two regions hit
more and less sensitive
regions on the rental
surface, thereby activating
the opposite cells-- here
activating the OFF cells,
here activating the ON cells.
Sorry-- right, yeah.
We got a reversal.
So that explains why
you see the after image.
So now we're going to
continue and get back
to the question of
the color circle,
see what happens with
after images with color.
So this color circle is
unbelievably powerful
because it explains the after
images that you see with color.
And I will come
back to this circle.
But what I want
you to do now again
is to fixate here, count
until, again, about 30,
and then fixate on the bottom.
So if you do that, I think
most of you should see,
again, a reversal.
Here you would see some reddish.
Here you would see
something greenish.
Does everybody see that?
Do you see that too?
Good.
So you have a very
minor color deficit.
So that's the case here.
So now let me show
you another one.
And again, do the
same experiment.
And what you see here at the
after images you get-- whoops.
Sorry.
Let me go back.
The after images
you get here are not
going to be the
complimentaries here.
So what's going on?
So let me explain it to you.
Here again is a color circle.
And here the prime axes.
It turns out that if you
adapt to this level here,
the rule of the color circle
says if you go across,
this is the after image
you're going to see.
And if you adapt to here,
this is the after image
you're going to see.
So let me draw that up.
It looks like that.
And that is true everywhere, as
long as you go across the axis.
You could do this horizontally
or even diagonally,
and you get this reversal.
So it says that an after image
can be perfectly predicted
by the rules of
the color circle.
It's on the opposite
side of the image
that you look at,
going across the center
along the cardinal axis.
But now if you do the diagonals,
which I showed you before,
when it didn't match,
what we have here,
you have this and this.
Then the after image
is this and that.
And so we don't have a
correspondence, of course,
because you're not along the
axes that would predict this.
This one gives you that
and this one give you that.
So if I did this and
this to begin with,
it would be the same
as that, but rotated.
So that then clearly enables
us to use the color circle
to predict not only some of the
basic effects of what colors
we see, but also to tell
you exactly what kinds
of after images you get.
Quite remarkable.
So now to drive
this home once more.
This doesn't work too well
because the colors are crummy
here, but we can try it.
Everybody agree this is sort of
a more or less black and white
display-- a little
bluish, unfortunately,
here-- of a beautiful castle?
See that fixation point here?
What I want you to do
here is to fixate here,
again, count to 30, and
then I'll switch back to it.
And if this were
to work right, you
would see the original black
and white image in color.
Keep fixating.
Count to 20 more.
And then I'll switch back.
Did you see the colors?
Yeah.
So this is a very
clever demo I found.
I'm afraid I don't
remember the person's name
who came up with this one.
But the essence of it is, again,
that indeed what is happening
is that you're creating an
after effect due to adaptation
in the retina.
And when you do
this very cleverly,
like this particular
castle picture,
you can actually create
an artificial impression
of colors which are in
consonance with what
the real colors would look like
in a black and white picture.
So that then is
the essence of what
I wanted to cover
about adaptation.
And we can now
come and summarize
what I had covered today.
So first of all, I
told you that there
are three qualities of
color-- hue, brightness,
and saturation.
And just to go back--
hang on for a minute.
I want to go back once
more to make this clear,
which I forgot to mention.
If you go around the
circle, you change hue.
And if you go from the
periphery to the center,
you change saturation.
And the center here, if this
color circle were 100% correct,
this would be a white area.
Now, the basic rules
of color vision
are explained by the color
circle, as we have amply seen.
There's something probably--
I have a color circle
up on my wall in my office
because I'm always fascinated
by this, even though I've
been doing it for years.
So the three photoreceptors
we talked about in humans
and in primates, the red,
green, and blue, which
shouldn't be called that.
People get mad when you do
that, even though that's the way
I call it.
But people want to call
them short, medium,
and long-wavelength cones.
They are broadly tuned,
as I had shown you
in those spectrograms.
The color-opponent midget
retinal ganglion cells
form two cardinal axes, the
red/green and the blue/yellow.
And those, if you
remember I told you
at the level of the
retinal ganglion cells
and at the level of the
lateral geniculate nucleus,
fall into these two
major categories.
We won't have any
under diagonals.
So for us to be properly
able to see diagonals,
that's done somewhere
in the cortex.
It's not done at the
level of the retina
or the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
Now, I also pointed out
to you several times
already that the midget
system's essential for color
discrimination.
And the parasol cells can see
stimuli even at isoluminance.
They just cannot say
what the color is.
They don't, quotes,
"perceive" different colors.
But they can see
any kind of change
that occurs in the
environment, even when it
occurs at isoluminance.
Color is processed in
many cortical areas,
lesions to any single
extrastriate area
fails to eliminate
the processing
of chrominance information.
It can reduce it, but
it doesn't block it out.
That's true for many things.
So the cortical areas
are very, very complex.
And they do interactive analysis
for many different attributes,
including color.
However, I can add here that
does not apply to area MT
because MT does not
seem to be specializing
in color because lesions there,
you [INAUDIBLE] any deficit.
But there's several
other visual areas.
We went through that, V3, and
[INAUDIBLE] cortex, and so on.
These areas contribute to
the processing of color.
Now, the perception
of isoluminance
is categorized for all
categories of vision.
It's not selected
to only those that
are processed by the midget
or the parasol systems.
All aspects of vision--
and the three I
showed you was,
stereopsis, motion,
and what was the third one?
AUDIENCE: Texture.
PROFESSOR: Texture, right.
So all three of
those are compromised
when stimuli are
presented at isoluminance.
The most significant aspect
of luminance adaptation
occurs in the photoreceptors.
And it's explainable by the
relative number at any given
level of adaptation of bleached
and unbleached photoreceptor
molecules, as in the
case of rhodopsin.
Lastly, after images are
a product of photoreceptor
adaptation and their subsequent
response to the incoming light.
So that then is the essence of
what you wanted to cover today.
And I hope you did
find this interesting,
because certainly
our ability to see
color is quite a
remarkable thing.
It's amazing to get a sense
of how the nervous system does
that, even though
at this stage, we
are still at a fairly
early level of having
gained full understanding of it.
Now the next time,
we are going to move
on to another fascinating topic,
at least for me fascinating,
which is depth perception,
which I had mentioned
before is a remarkable
achievement because images fall
on a two-dimensional
retinal surface.
And from that, the
third dimension
has to be reconstructed.
And how that is done, we are
going to discuss the next time.
Now let's make sure that all
of you had signed attendance.
And the next thing is if any
of you have any questions,
I will be happy to
try to answer them.
So once again, I'm
crystal clear, huh?
Well, thank you very
much for attending.
And I do hope that
your knowledge
has increased a bit about how
we process color information.